hey everybody and welcome to a
surprising wild ride with stevo i wasn't
ready for how warm and friendly chelsea
handler was going to be because the
experience i had with her on her show i
felt like she was tearing me to pieces
and you know what there are more
surprises in store maybe even a surprise
guest so this is just enlightening it's
refreshing and it's wonderful so let's
get into it
how's it going chelsea
hi honey bunny how are you
super good super good and we got
everything recording we're good we'll
dive right into it we don't want to
waste your time
okay let's go boys let's do it
all right this is how we do it
ladies and gentlemen
chelsea handler yeah dude
so good to see you dude
i want you to meet my co-host scott
randolph hi chelsea
hi scott randolph up at the front of the
van we've got the gorgeous paul briskey
hi chelsea nice to meet you oh hi paul
are you guys doing this out of the van
yep it's the creepy van podcast down by
the river i love it
i love it and you saw ice cream
jolly ranchers yeah we got all kinds of
cats
all the good stuff right yeah so so what
what an honor thank you for doing this
um congratulations on your on everything
i mean shoot we've both been at it for
now we can say decades huh
oh my god yeah we're old we're all well
we're middle aged we're middle-aged
we're not quite old and in l.a well i
don't think you're in l.a are you in l.a
i am i am i'm in hollywood okay well in
l.a you know mid-40s is still young
because of everything we can do to take
care of ourselves so i just try and
focus on that wow um i
i suppose you know
i'm on my second book now and and i'm
under all this like
stress because i have to deliver the
manuscript on october 15th and it's a
lot of work and i'm like oh my god
um but the book is sort of my guide to
middle age
and as i've worked really yeah
as i've worked on it i've arrived at the
conclusion that while father time is
undefeated
some people put up a much better fight
than others
uh i would say that's true it's a well
to quote one of my best friends it's a
dog fight once you hit 40 everything
starts to work against you so you have
to work extra hard to say [ __ ] off i'm
gonna like you know thrive i mean i have
to say at 46
i feel like i am
killing it in terms of keeping my [ __ ]
together looking good being healthy it
took me a really long time to get there
but i'm here now so like
if somebody had told me when i was 25
i'd have the body i'd want when i was 45
i wouldn't have believed them but i'll
[ __ ] take it yeah well hey i concur
you look fantastic as do i
as do you what's your dog's name steve
this is wendy and i found her on the
streets of peru
oh
that's where i did ayahuasca was peru
yeah there were so many dogs there it
was terrible i'm glad you got one where
in peru were you
uh we were off we were at some lodge off
of a tributary like off the amazon um on
some big river and we went to uh what
was it called i don't know i won't think
of it more food butterfly experience
was that what it's called yes no it
wasn't that but it was called something
like zankita or akita it has akita at
the end anyway we went to a uh lodge
with a shaman who
uh yeah guided us during our i did it
for my netflix documentary chelsea does
which was a series i did and one was
called chelsea does drugs so i just did
a bunch of different drugs and they
filmed me and we went to peru and did
the ayahuasca which was an incredible
experience they warned me they were like
listen you know a lot of people if you
want to film this like you're going to
vomit and a lot of people [ __ ] their
pants and i was like uh i'm a [ __ ]
professional i'm not gonna [ __ ] my pants
on camera and ruin a great buzz that's
just not gonna happen
wow did you [ __ ] your pants
no i didn't [ __ ] my pants i got a period
i gotta believe that if you did [ __ ]
your pants that you would have been
fairly candid about that
yeah i don't keep anything back i like
to give it all i like to get i like
people depend on me for you know being
honest so at least i should deliver that
much right yeah
you know i i'm uh
scott and i both are are recovering
alcoholics and drug addicts and and we
hear a lot about people
going to do ayahuasca as like some
function of like getting sober and it
seems counterintuitive to us but uh they
yeah they they describe it like going
through hell
and then
working out all of your demons and you
come out what was it like
it was pretty great i mean people do say
that they say you go and then you quit
drinking or you quit using i mean you
know not everybody i mean maybe if
that's your intention to do it can be
helpful in that way uh but it was it was
just this crazy it's like you see all
these snapshots of your life but you're
not in your life you're watching it from
like you know 30 000 feet above like
there was all these these childhood
memories that were real and true like my
dogs from childhood that you know i
didn't even wasn't thinking about but
they'd be running on the beach it would
be me and my sister at my parents summer
house and all like we were wearing the
bathing suits we wore so there were
scenes that have actually happened but
that are so far
in the you know recess part of your
brains that you're just not even tapping
into that stuff and so you get to kind
of see your life it's like an ipod
shuffle
of your life and you're just hearing
kind of deep meaning like spiritual
kind of lessons about how to behave like
mine was about my sister it was like be
kind or be gentler to your sister my
sister i always kind of you know bullied
because she just wasn't ever as
motivated or as ambitious as me and it
was like your sister's not you and
you're not right either so be kinder and
nicer to her you know stop trying to get
her to be like you your your life isn't
for everyone and so it had a big impact
on me i haven't done it again because of
the vomiting you know and the potential
[ __ ] i'm not that drawn to that but
yeah people love ayahuasca everyone's
doing it now
wow that's kind of the thing to do was
there a point when you did it and you're
like oh [ __ ] what did i do or were you
like bring it on as soon as you did it
no i was just really you know i have a
very good reaction to drugs psychedelics
any sort of like i always go in and i
just have like an open mind and i think
that's the first thing when you're doing
those kinds of drugs if you if you're
fear-based and you're scared shitless
then you're not going to have a great
experience um but my shaman did [ __ ] his
pants actually twice during the surgery
amateur hour
yeah and he did not get up to go to the
bathroom or leave the room so
um while i mean while you watch that you
can see the smell permeating through the
room and me
in the middle of my trip going
what is that oh damn i want to know
between the two of us which one of us
has a stronger urge to do ayahuasca
after that description
probably me yeah yeah i've seen you [ __ ]
yourselves
do you have a favorite psychedelic
steve could [ __ ] his pants without
ayahuasca
i do it all the time
you know i was uh i was talking to my
girl who by the way um doesn't want me
to let on how big of a fan of yours she
is she wants me to play that cool
uh and she wants you to know that she's
um a stylist she's a production designer
a prop stylist a wardrobe specialist
and um
she's and and she told me that you don't
want to have kids
and and neither do we i got a vasectomy
i absolutely it's our favorite thing
um
you getting wait you getting a vasectomy
is your favorite thing
well yeah like i made a great
bid out of it which i filmed for my new
tour called the vasectomy olympics
and it's a
hump and dump all month long
oh i see i see hump and dump i got it
that's very very romantic too
right up your alley
wednesday hump and dump night
[Laughter]
so she's really excited that we're
talking to you and i told her
that i said you know i'm intimidated to
talk to chelsea
i'm going to tell you something else
that intimidates me and i can't believe
how hard this is to admit
but i don't get enough greens man
veggies dude i just feel like man i
don't want to eat them all the time but
now i found a g1
from athletic greens and dude i was just
open-minded to try this you can have it
on a completely empty stomach which
works great and when i tried it i'm like
wait a second this stuff is delicious
so this is what i do every single
morning i go ahead and fill up a cup
because i know i gotta hydrate before i
start pounding coffee
and i pound it down
and just get some
just to get some water in there
and then
scoop in my ag-1 right here and this is
going to take care of my gut it's going
to give me in one serving all of the
the nutrition
all of the probiotics all the vitamins
it's just like a once daily
multivitamin that does not destroy my
stomach that tastes great and gives me
all the stuff that i'm not getting
enough of i do this every single morning
and when i'm on tour i bring my ag-1
packets with the once daily
telling you i think that everybody needs
to have this
and if you go to athleticgreens.com
stevo you're gonna get
five of these daily travel packets plus
an entire year's worth of vitamin d with
your first order telling you dude these
ag-1 packets they're a lifesaver so
go to athleticgreens.com
stevo and get yourself
five free packets a year's worth of
vitamin d
with your first order and just discover
this stuff man i'm telling you it's the
fountain of youth
now let's talk to chelsea about being
intimidated by her
and she said she said why that's because
well many many years ago i was on her
show and she just tore me apart the
whole time was sort of my experience
and uh yeah i remember
i don't think that's what happened steve
i i kind of i mean i don't know i was
probably pretty loaded but but uh i i
think that's kind of what happened i
felt like
but which is great you know i mean i
think it was funny i think you did your
job fantastically well and
and i just i think do you find that
people are intimidated by you quite a
lot yeah yeah a lot mostly white men are
intimidated by me
we're [ __ ] our pants over here are
you guys all [ __ ] your pants right
now
um no i find that i don't know why um
strong confident women can be so
intimidating you know we're just i mean
i think it should be celebrated you guys
should be happy that we're independent
and that we're fierce instead of being
so scared of us i mean i don't want to
be intimidating you know i'm not setting
out to be intimidating i'm just trying
to be myself so when people say oh
you're scary or you're intimidating it's
like well really that's a bummer to hear
i get it but you know i'm not trying to
um you know d i'm not trying to
emasculate anyone i mean some people i
am but definitely not everybody
well that's comforting
that that's comforting and not you stevo
i know you need your masculinity and you
are masculine okay so from god's from my
mouth to god's ears to your lips or
however that [ __ ] goes around
i don't know that it's a masculinity
question i think it was more of a
you know like like like a dirt bag kind
of a thing
what you felt like a dirt bag on her
show
i don't know
i think i was a dirtbag
i was probably loaded what year was it
uh well he said that if i was promoting
dr steva that would have been i was at
my worst and 2007. yeah maybe you're
just in your head yeah who knows i mean
who knows
well what do you remember about it
chelsea i just remember we had a good
time i don't remember any details you
know i just remember oh like when they
said oh do you want to do stevo's
podcast oh yeah i love that guy oh i
appreciate it so so much um so
your your new tour is called vaccinated
and horny
that's right i love it i i think that's
fantastic
i think a lot of people are feeling that
way right you know we've been in and
this was this nightmare for two years
that is an ending um and it's starting
to open up and we're all able to like go
to events and i really want it to be the
reason to bring people back together in
a fun [ __ ] way you know and be like
okay let's all make fun of the way we
behave for the last two years um and
let's talk about it and and have a
joyful experience of of being together
in large crowds and laughing again and
togetherness you know everyone's so
pissed off all the time so it's a really
nice time to be a comedian i think and
get out there oh man i i i'm i'm loving
it
yeah i kick it off i kick it off next
week in cincinnati and then i'm going to
cities all across the country for the
next like six months um you can get
tickets at chelseahandler.com or
livenation but yeah yeah i'm really
really psyched it's been fun and it's
going to continue
fantastic and and you're doing like just
full-blown arenas
uh well i don't know if they're no not
arenas big feeders i think like 2 000
seats three thousand okay
yeah do you travel around a tour bus or
do you fly everywhere you go or are you
what are you feeling yeah
i don't know i i don't have a tour bus
that's not really my jam but who knows
who knows what the hell's gonna happen
every time i say i'm not gonna do
something i end up doing it um but yeah
i fly around everywhere pretty much you
go for a weekend and then you know if
the cities are close enough you can
drive and stuff but
you said you kick off next week so how
many airplanes have you been on since
the pandemic shutdown
oh my god the airplane situation the
announcements that they have to make at
the beginning of flights about
passengers keeping their masks above
their nose and not touching the flight
attendants it's like are you kidding me
it's like we're living in a real time
like a real live [ __ ] zoo i mean
flight attendants have to take
self-defense classes
yesterday who was taking karate classes
and i'm like what are you [ __ ]
kidding me she's like no i have to
defend myself for people who refuse to
put their masks on it's unbelievable
yeah it's great they have to announce
like and please don't be an [ __ ] on
this flight like you shouldn't have to
say that
also if you're not planning on wearing a
mask like at this point in time you know
that it's a requirement so if you're
going to the airport and intending not
to wear a mask you know that there's a
chance you're going to get duct taped to
your seat
that video of that dude duct taping the
passenger i mean he almost turned into a
zombie he was like
flailing
i know
look at the videos of people screaming
on planes about where it's like they've
just heard about wearing masks you know
like i can't believe
what i mean it's great it's crazy
and um
having that because i was i was on this
comedy club grind for like 10 years and
it was every week go just groundhog day
and the whole thing and you know scott's
my tour manager so that we would go
together but right before the pandemic
shutdown i i was on the set of our cool
new jackass four movie it's jackass
forever and i got a call from my agent
saying congratulations we don't have to
mess around with any more comedy clubs
you've graduated to theaters and i'm
like yeah
and then like
the next week
the movie was shut down the tour was
shut down like you know
it was kind of kind of a bummer you know
but what what happened over the you know
the subsequent year and a half
we started the podcast we like got
more involved in all these different
areas and and like the groundhog's day
was over it was all like fun new
exciting new things and now that we're
back to flying and touring airports are
like 10 000 times more annoying and you
have to wear a mask so dude
like one weekend we were begging for a
tour bus
oh no i know what you mean it's like the
most you i mean i'm like listen if
there's an if it's under four hours
drive us from one city to the next
because that even when you are on a
plane and you like there's all this
protocol now right about cleaning the
planes in between flights because of
covet yet for some reason they're more
disgusting than ever like if you look
under your seat or you look in between
your armrest and the and the window and
look down it's like you know somebody
had a wafer party three months ago that
still hasn't been addressed so there's
not enough sanitation in the world and
yeah planes are definitely also you know
covert revealed to us just how dirty we
all are and how easily germs spread you
know i guess you we could have figured
that out on our own but for a lot of us
i was like oh god i didn't know we were
all spreading disease like that so now
when you're on a plane and you see germs
and like you see crumbs you're just like
oh
so um
it's always good it's always good you
guys just to wear a sanitary napkin
i in a diaper
i i uh
and
in a lot of ways i pride myself on being
a dirt bag
that's right i think the key to keeping
your immune system on its toes is to
expose yourself to as many germs as
possible and you know what else is
really good for you
water who knew man this stuff keeps you
alive and maybe you're the kind of
person who drinks a lot of soda or diet
soda you know what that's my dad and if
you switch to liquid death sparkling
water like my dad did you're gonna be a
lot healthier probably lose a bunch of
weight and i just subscribe to drinking
this stuff all the time because the more
water i drink the healthier i am and how
about that man i feel cool holding this
rad tall boy whether it's my sparkling
water or my still mountain water it's
just a great company that's saving the
world how well
let me tell you that plastic is no
longer recyclable i mean it's destroying
the world plastic and that's why this
stuff is called liquid death because
they're trying to bring death to plastic
these tall boys are infinitely
recyclable plus 10 of the profits this
company make go to helping rid the world
of plastic man come on this company's
great water is really good for you and
if you go to liquiddeth.como
you get all free shipping on every order
of water and merch and their merch is
super dope so come on man support the
podcast support this awesome company and
get on over to liquiddeth.com
stevo for free shipping on all your
orders of water in march yeah dude now
let's talk more about being a scumbag
i'm the antithesis of a germaphobe
i make a point of of guzzling tap water
in every country i've ever go to
the only one yeah the only continent
i've not guzzled tap water in is
antarctica because i've never been there
and they don't have it and they're
watering and their water is [ __ ]
pretty pure i think anyway yeah
antarctica seems like they probably
might have the best water how did that
work out for you in mexico mexico easy
in kenya i got a little bit sick
uh-huh and what about um where's the oh
india have you had tap water in india i
think i got through india no problem
you must have some
yeah i've been to uh what am i up to 57
countries you're drinking them in every
57 countries
in peru you drank toilet water
yeah
in peru
i scooped a mug into the toilet and and
drank it if anybody can get get away
with that steve it's definitely you so
thank you for taking one for the entire
team yeah well thank you i mean
meanwhile i'm doing a meet and greet
with steve and washing my hands six
times throughout the whole thing wearing
a mask and he's just like ordering more
nachos not washing his hands
licking his fingers to get the sauce off
of it and just let it and i'm sick more
than he is i don't understand him yeah
well obviously he's gotten so many germs
in his system that he can fight off
anything steve did you get kovid
um not that i was aware of but at one
point i randomly i randomly got an
antibodies test which turned up positive
you're probably you're probably patient
number one and you don't even know it
india tap water i mean i i don't know
because yeah i'm in i'm in bed with my
girl every single night she didn't have
the antibodies and with him every day he
didn't have the antibodies paul's my
editor were shoulder to shoulder and
edit bait constantly and he didn't have
the antibodies i think i developed the
antibodies like
just
i'm a mutant i don't know are you yeah
yeah chelsea you're in la right
yeah well right now i'm in albany so
don't be too jealous but yes i live in
l.a the craziest thing because i grew up
in l.a and you know the l.a river is not
really a river it's like that wash that
washes through it
it's like a super drought steel it was a
yeah
water in there steve fell into it
surfing and he swallowed a couple huge
gulps of water
and that's the craziest thing i've ever
seen happen surfing the l.a river yeah
it's a stretch to call that surfing but
uh in in any case i've been very
deliberate
it was more like boogie boarding steve
yeah for sure
i think your uh your immune system is
like a muscle and you want to work it
out to keep it strong and so that's what
i do is i welcome germs and as a result
i think i've
become pretty bulletproof
yeah it sounds like you're you've beat
the system so way to go yeah um so so
there's so there's so much fun and
exciting stuff to to talk to you about
like you're very outspoken about
political stuff
you don't shy away from it
well i feel like if you don't [ __ ]
say something then you're just a big
[ __ ] you know what i mean right like i
feel like if you don't have a strong
opinions about stuff and you don't stand
up for what you believe in then what's
the point
exactly i think there is a
contingent of the population that has a
valid point when they say they don't
really want to hear
like a lot of celebrities weighing in on
politics and and morality but i think
you've earned yourself uh an exception
seat to that rule i think that when you
speak up that it is
valid that it is
worth listening to
well i appreciate that and i also think
you know when people say that it's like
what because i'm successful i don't get
to weigh in on that because i i pay
taxes i i you know what i mean like just
because you're a celebrity and you make
a good living doesn't mean you're that
precludes you or excludes you from
having a political opinion i'm a voter i
get to express my views just like any
other [ __ ] person so anybody who says
we don't want to hear from celebrities
or tells lebron james to shut up and
dribble is is an idiot too it's not like
we're not members of society we just
have bigger platforms so it becomes a
little bit louder so yes i don't ever
feel anything um regretful about you
know sounding off i love it you know i i
shove [ __ ] up my ass for a living and
and i have an opinion too i pay taxes
any [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh
can become a parent i mean you gotta get
a license to catch a fish
you gotta get a license to to do
anything but you don't have to get a
license to become a parent can we like
maybe put something in place to prevent
[ __ ] faces from having kids
yeah it would be great if men had to get
vasectomies and then undo them when they
were ready to have a child because then
that process would be you know a big
barrier of entry like you did perfect
poster child you could do an ad for
vasectomies and then if you haven't
already which you probably have
and then when they are really serious
and then decide yeah you know what i do
want to have a child then they can
reverse that vasectomy right and go for
it get a circumcision and a vasectomy
when you're born i think so and i'll
take it one step further because the
vasectomy
all they're doing is cutting the tube
which delivers the sperm from the balls
to the weiner
that they
they disrupt that that delivery and then
after you cut that you don't have to put
the tube back together you don't have to
to reverse the vasectomy all you have to
do is extract the semen from the balls
it's still being produced in the balls
it's just not coming out the weiner and
that does mean that you have to get a
needle
like in injected into your balls which
is definitely not going to be the most
comfortable thing which reserves
parenthood for people who really want it
exactly
i agree with you you should work really
extra [ __ ] hard if you want a baby
you don't just get to have sex and be
like oh i didn't want to be a father
it's like well why don't you decide when
you want to be a father and then you can
go through all those motions you
mentioned yeah and and and women like
childbirth is the most like painful
[ __ ] thing ever like and guys just
skate by and guys should have to have a
big ass needle in their balls
you know if they want to have kids
yeah i mean balls are yeah i think balls
are ripe for being poked
yeah
yeah i i love it and um
so your your nudity is great
nice transition
just kidding
you mentioned that you vote and with
your i voted stickers on your nipples
that was great
yeah well i take yeah i take voting and
my nipples very seriously but i like to
do an annual ski video each year on my
birthday where i have a place in
whistler canada because i love to ski so
i go there for winter and then i um like
a white person i winter in whistler and
i liked it on my birthday ski down the
mountain topless and with a margarita
and a joint just to remind women that
they have choices to make in life and if
you make the right ones you can do what
i do i love it
i i love it with freeing the female
nipple like where is the opposition
because i don't
you know most men are like yeah walk
around topless for sure and most women
are like [ __ ] questions why can't i
walk around topless like who
who's against it i don't know like and
why can gross men walk around topless
they're not even their breasts can't
even feed like we can feel we can feed a
human being right you have these magical
things yeah yeah we should be
celebrating that and instead we have to
see fat [ __ ] walking around with their
shirts off running through the city it's
like i want to run around with my shirt
well i don't because it's painful but i
want to walk around with my shirt off
you know what i mean some of these men
have bigger tits than women and they're
they're i don't know i know and those
are disgusting i i i couldn't agree more
i i had a bit that i really am proud of
where i decided
since women can paint their boobs
and walk around as if like nothing's
wrong
then i should be able to paint my dick
and do whatever i want
well i mean you're getting ahead of
yourself because women painting their
boobs isn't that's okay in like san
francisco in another city it's still not
a universal thing so i think you have to
out of respect for women steve wait
until we're able to all just be painted
topless and whatever and then you can
introduce your balls to the situation i
couldn't wait i i i went ahead and did
it and
[Laughter]
it was pretty awesome
it was pretty good
yeah we i made a hardcore cyclist suit
with spandex shirt and and like the
helmet and the bike and everything but
we just painted on the shorts and then i
went riding the bicycle around and
crashing it in front of random dudes on
the sidewalk so that they would see me
crash and come over and reach their hand
out to to help me up and find my my
schlong
oh yeah how is that well yeah that's a
great system that you put into place
were they able to grip that as like a
handlebar
yeah it was it was pretty awesome until
we we were pretty careful to avoid women
and children you know like we scouted i
was in the car and it was just the bike
was on a rack and i would jump out and
grab on the bike and
but at one point i got out of the car to
grab the bike and there was like a whole
little kids soccer team getting out of a
van or something right next to us and
i'm just like okay guys we're
we're gonna wrap this one early
yeah it's tricky when there are kids
around right that's always a buzz kill
you know what else to do we filmed that
bit like the very week that louis c.k
had his uh bad week
oh yeah when he we found out he was
masturbating in front of random people
it was a rough time to be breaking out
your dog in public yes
but hey man you know that's me
yeah that's you exactly
so so dude i i was on joe coy's podcast
just like a week or two ago
you were yeah and so i'm like yeah and i
know that i'm not trying to like say
anything that we haven't seen on tmz
like but and i just want to to tell you
that
that the joy you've expressed for your
new relationship i completely understand
because joe coy and i i would say
fell in love with each other just like
joe
come here
rad
i'm on the i'm on stevo's podcast he
said you he was on your podcast a couple
weeks ago
come say hi he's like wow he's like who
yeah
i just got done servicing him hold on
one second
yeah dude
how you doing bro
steve oh dude i just told chelsea that
you and i fell in love with each other a
couple weeks oh yeah stevo you're a
brilliant man yeah
what a rad time and i just can't speak
highly enough of you and i told chelsea
that i completely understand why she has
expressed so much joy for her new
relationship with you oh
you're the best that makes perfect sense
to me now is it since i have you
together i saw it oh [ __ ] here we go god
that's that's how you set him up
[Music]
that's the love huh don't go just yet
now jill i saw you on tmz yesterday they
asked you guys both which which of you
is funnier and you were very gentlemanly
you jumped up very quickly to say
chelsea's funnier oh but that's the
truth though she is okay well i i i
submit to you
that comedy is very subjective so that's
a matter of opinion some people are
going to think you're funnier
yeah well obviously steve you [ __ ] do
because you're bringing this up
but but what is not subjective is
numbers so which one of you is richer
yeah we have to we have to bring it we
have to compare our bank account yeah
yeah yeah i haven't done that yet every
new relationship so we really haven't
done that kind of we don't have
spreadsheet information yet
if you were to believe celebrity net
worth stuff which is just so like
hilariously wrong like 98 of the time
then chelsea is is considerably more
wealthy but okay
it went from jokes to
hey man
this is steve steven's like i know who's
funnier it's the person with the most
money
well i mean but joe i think they're
super light on you man i think that
they've really grossly underestimated
you they don't they they haven't seen
where you're going if you're comparing
the size of venues that you guys are
going to on tour then joe's got it by a
mile
yeah he is playing bigger venues that's
for sure yeah he is and that's why he's
working this weekend so he can start
saving money so he can have as much as i
do
i think i'm visibly blushing i'm i'm
embarrassed for having put you guys
through that and uh and i'm gonna stop i
i just i i had such a wonderful time
with you joe
where's your dog chelsea wants to see
your dog yeah
i didn't see her oh she's the best yeah
dude i don't do much without wendy wendy
from peru and you know you said that it
was sad that there are dogs everywhere
in peru but i judge
countries i judge them based on the the
situation that i see the street dogs in
and they're doing pretty well for
themselves in peru are they then why did
you take wendy because i loved her
i wasn't trying to help her i i found
myself uh
extremely um needy for her like like it
was a purely selfish move she's so
wonderful
well it seems like you guys have a very
strong connection from the way her head
is in your lap yeah yeah no no doubt
no doubt in your tattooed balls okay
yeah he was talking about that earlier
painted balls yeah yeah with that with
the whole bit so yeah man
like
how much are you guys going to be able
to see each other if you're both on
separate tours
i'll fly to her when she's off i'll fly
to her when i'm off and she'll do the
same we're here right now for his
weekend he's performing all weekend so
uh we're doing that
and then i start back up next weekend
and then we're both on tour for the next
for the foreseeable future so mondays
tuesdays and wednesdays wednesdays are
our days
nice dude epic and and what's your
position on airports joe
what again your position on airports
chelsea doesn't seem phased by uh but
we're over here begging for tour buses
yeah steve hates him i i do i love says
it joe's on a tour of us too we flew
into new york but then we took the tour
bus up to albany yeah joe loves taking
buses i love it
yeah i mean i like getting harassed like
every three feet in an airport while
you're wearing a mask you know so that
ugh
but we do we do a different type of
service though
where you just
they walk you right to the back you
don't do that stephen
why are you going through general
population steve dude are you a
concierge key
what a good what a good move for you to
do steve at an airport is wear your mask
where your glasses they'll fog up and
then you can act like you can't see
anything yeah we tried that one time we
went to comic-con and he was like i'm
gonna dress up like a storm trooper and
he went in there like dressed like a
storm trooper and 5 000 people wanted to
take photos with the storm trooper
everywhere we went we stopped to take
photos of the storm trooper
we oh man this is so great okay my girl
told me that you know and i heard about
the whole you know dynamic with joe on
on your chelsea lately show and and joe
was supposed to be the sidekick but he
said oh i don't want to be the sidekick
and and you went off on him you blew it
like yeah by the way i don't remember
that story at all that's a story that he
tells and i have no recollection of i
don't remember ever asking you to be my
sidekick on that show right so that's
one of the figments of your imagination
that's gonna that's gonna really [ __ ] my
story yeah right right right and then
the story goes on that you know let's
remember hey let's just put it this way
steve there's a lot of things in her
past that she doesn't remember
all right so let's let's not blame that
on memory let's just blame that on okay
so
i've forgotten more than some of you
will ever remember
i i i don't doubt it i don't doubt it
but but i trust my girl my girl said
that that joe was very regular on your
show and that you
were particularly
harsh to joe out of anybody on the show
that you would really tear them apart
make fun of them the whole time and uh i
thought
that was i thought that was interesting
it's like like uh like when we're kids
like we're really mean to the person
that we like
hey steve yeah that's what i've been
saying right
so basically what you're saying is she
had a crush on me yeah during the show
is that what you're saying i think so
yeah i think so too i think that's what
i've been saying
i think it was she doesn't remember yeah
is it true
[Laughter]
shuffle memory that just went in the
trash
you know um i spoke my first words in
portuguese because after being born in
england i moved to brazil when i was six
months old and uh then i spoke spanish
when i was two and then i moved to
america when i was four
learned three languages by the age of
three forgot two of them completely by
the age of five but when i was in summer
camp at 11 years old they said i was
speaking portuguese in my sleep so
everything that ever happens is very
much in there we don't necessarily have
access to it but it makes sense to me
that when you do the ayahuasca trip that
you like
get access to all of these details which
you would never otherwise ever
yeah you'd be speaking fluent in all
three languages probably
probably great i mean what an honor and
and i can't even believe this you guys
i'm
reasonably sure
have blessed us with like
with like crazy stories picked up by
this or that i mean wow
i mean just making our podcast a big
deal and speaking of them chelsea
i think this is the first time you and i
have done anything is with stevo other
than the tmz people catching you yeah
oh yeah well joe called ahead to make
sure that they were outside
charlie
yeah he loves tmz yeah he can't get
enough of that [ __ ] yeah i let them know
i
love that so much but you've got your
your new podcast season two is gonna be
starting up soon let's let's promote
that let's promote yeah dear chelsea
season two
uh premieres next week or the week after
yeah that's fun i give lots of um no i
give a lot of solicited advice since i
spent my whole career giving unsolicited
advice i figured why not have people ask
me real questions and then i can just
guide them through life you know with a
little extra oomph some people just need
a little shove in the right direction if
you know what i mean yeah
for sure i i i couldn't agree more so so
uh dear chelsea is the podcast get ready
for your podcast honey bunny the koi
pond
actually gonna do this i was actually
gonna come out and tell a world about
this
dressed up as a stormtrooper
that won't [ __ ] work either right oh
it's it's fantastic and so uh tickets
for both of you it's joe joecoy.com for
tickets to your tour
chelseahandler.com for tickets to your
tour your instagram handles on the
social media are just your names
yeah
there you go so let's fight let's follow
you guys on social media let's get
tickets to your tours let's listen to
your podcast and let's make sure that we
have all five of chelsea's best-selling
books yeah i think it's six steve okay
oh yeah six
six
you're worried about number two that's
safe in spanish oh yeah that's stace
yeah yeah
i think that's even in portuguese
it's amazing i i i
i love you guys both i love you together
i admire you i respect you i'm honored
to know you and thank you so much for
this wonderful time with you oh thanks
guys nice seeing you yeah
thank you
amazing how about that dudes telling you
chelsea handler she's amazing my girl
loves her and tell you a little secret
my
girl is going to be on the podcast
it's a big big deal
we've uh taken our relationship to
yeah no man thank you guys it's uh it's
crazy dude it's a wild ride we're still
going we're still riding it's awesome
thank you for being here i love you